OK, so let's now get into the it's not even
really a mia culpa interview that Ted Cruz
gave to Sean Hannity on Fox News because he
doesn't really say he did anything wrong other
than saying I realized. I think he says, like
as he was getting on the plane to go to Cancun,
convenient time to realize it, that maybe the
optics of the trip weren't quite so good. So
let's get into Ted Cruz's various explanations
for the misguided trip to Cancun last week. Again,
to reset the story for you. Texas gets hit with
storms and cold, which causes power outages. Many
Republicans try to blame frozen wind farms for
the power outages. That's wrong. Most of the
problem with power, with electricity supply in
Texas was caused by frozen instruments at nuclear
power plants, at natural gas power plants and
at coal power plants. Yes, some windmills froze.
Mostly the problem was the fossil fuels and the
nuclear. And of course, the reason for this is
not because wind farms and nuclear and coal
and gas can't produce power in cold weather.
It's because Texas, even though a decade ago had
a similar power outage and got a report saying,
here's how you winterize all of these types of
power generation, they didn't do it. So that's
why this is going on. OK. So here are Ted Cruz's
explanations for why in the midst of all this,
he decided to go to Cancun and then come
back first. Relatively early in the scandal,
Ted Cruz's office put out a statement basically
throwing his own daughters under the bus, saying,
quote, With school canceled for the week,
our girls asked to take a trip with friends
wanting to be a good dad. He just wants to be a
good dad to everybody with wanting to be a good
dad. I flew down with them last night and I'm
flying back this afternoon. Now, unfortunately,
the decision to fly back this afternoon was not
the originally scheduled trip of Ted Cruz. He
changed his ticket to fly back immediately 20
hours after landing because the story exploded.
And we know that Ted Cruz went down there with a
bunch of luggage. We later learned he had a flight
booked not for Friday, but for the weekend. So he
had to change his explanation. Once that got out,
he had intended to stay for several days. Cruz had
the amount of luggage I bring on a 10 day trip,
and he wanted us to believe it was a 20 hour
trip. So that one imploded very quickly.
Then Ted Cruz is interviewed at the Cancun airport
on his way back. Let's take a look at that video.
So I flew down with them last night, dropped
them off here. And I'm headed back to Texas
and back to continuing to work to try
to get the power of what's happening in
Texas is unacceptable to a lot of Texans of the
valiant and brave public servant heading back
from a 20 hour trip to get the power back on.
Wait a second. It wasn't even a vacation. He
was basically just chaperoning the flight
down and he was going to work remotely. OK,
so then Ted Cruz, upon returning to Texas, agrees
to do the big interview with Fox News propagandist
Sean Hannity to really clear the air and get back
on in the good graces of the American people.
It starts with Sean Hannity sucking up
to Ted Cruz. So right after we saw this,
we knew it wasn't going to be a real interview.
And then you were fully and completely engaged.
And I know that from my own reporting and
my own conversations with you and Governor
Abbott and which of us started
so apriori before the interview,
Sean Hannity already has cleared Ted
Cruz of wrongdoing. Great for Ted. So
then Hannity keeps doing it, keeps it going
and says, listen, you can be a senator and
just make a quick round trip to Cancun.
I think you can be a father and be the
senator of Texas all the same time and make a
round trip, quick drop off trip and come home.
Well, Sean, that's right, and Hannity barely
stopping short there of I would be worried
if you weren't going to Cancun in the midst of
this. Senator, what a hero and what a great father
you are. Thank you so much. OK, so finally, it's
Ted Cruz's turn and he goes into his explanation.
Our house was dark. We had no heat. Actually, the
fireplace behind me, we were all huddled around
the fireplace because it was the only heat in the
house. And after a couple of days after the girls
being really cold at being in the teens and
the 20s outside, our girls asked said, look,
school's been canceled for the week. Can
we take a trip and go somewhere warm? And
Heidi and I as parents, we said, OK, sure.
And so last night I flew down with them
to the beach and then I flew back this afternoon.
I had initially planned to stay through the
weekend and to work remotely there. But but as I
as I was heading down there, you know, I started
to have second thoughts almost immediately.
So notice there that Ted Cruz, because he was
outed as having a return, a round trip ticket
where he wasn't coming back until the weekend,
he had to say, I initially plan to stay through
the weekend, which is true. But he realized he
really should be in Texas, by which he means I got
caught. The blaming of the daughters is hilarious,
too. And I was thinking, like, what kid demands
to go on vacation the next day to Mexico
and gets the OK from their parents that growing
up for me and all of my friends, vacations and
trips were planned in advance. Hey, Mom and Dad,
let's go to Cancun tomorrow, like in 12 hours.
Sure. Let's do it. I'm just trying to be a good
dad. This was simply escaping a bad situation in
the United States and fleeing across the US Mexico
border that way south for a better situation in
Cancun. That's all that this was. And then one
last clip, which is really funny. In continuing
to explain the Cancun trip, Ted Cruz casually
mentions that a lot of his daughter's friends
were over for dinner. There's a pandemic
going on. What are you doing? Having
multiple kids over from multiple households?
You know, we had a bunch of kids at our house
because our house was one of the few houses that
had power. And so we had a lot of our daughter's
friends were over. We're making dinner for
them and right about, I don't know, six,
six thirty boom, the lights go out and we lose
power. And so we had a candlelight dinner because
that's all we had. We had flashlights and then the
girls all camped out. They got in sleeping bags
and wrapped up in in in comforters and everything.
And then we flew to Cancun and it was all great.
Sean, truly, truly great. So a big explanation
from Ted Cruz that, quite frankly, explained
nothing other than what we thought, which is
Ted Cruz continues to live in his own world.
And when the outside world got into his life, he
lost power. He decided to flee across the border
to the country of Mexico. He should resign. There
are many calls for his resignation. He's not going
to resign. We'll have more coverage of this on our
Instagram at David Pakman show. By the way, if you
want to see what happened to my hair, thanks to
the wind over the weekend, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman. It's bizarre and it's probably
not something you want to let children see.
It's really a it's it's a it's a
hair disaster for lack of a better
term. Quick break. Back after this. The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.